votre audition se positionne à la suite
donc des personnes que nous venons donc
d'entendre qui était donc les de
l'Observatoire national de la rénovation
énergétique il nous espérons à travers
votre audition ne permettre de mieux
appréhender le pilotage de cette
politique publique Julien de Normandie
et Emmanuel Vergon ont été je crois à
l'origine de la création de cette
mission de coordination entre leurs deux
ministères ayant pris conscience que des
grandes administrations ne le faisaient
pas d'elle-même et que la plupart des
décisions remontaient à chaque fois à
l'arbitrage des deux cabinets c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui est manuel vargon a
indiqué à notre commission lors de son
audition la Commission a donc souhaité
vous entendre pour mieux comprendre la
gouvernance de cette politique c'est
donc le premier volet ce sera d'autant
plus utile que en juillet 2022 soit un
mois tout juste après votre prise de
fonction la Cour des comptes a émis un
certain nombre de critiques et à
demander le renforcement du pilotage
dans son référé sur la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments elle notait
notamment je la cite doté de faible
moyen cette mission de coordination
n'est pas équipée pour assumer le
pilotage national de la politique de
rénovation énergétique et en particulier
le suivi des actions en lien avec les
collectivités locales en outre la cour
recommandée de se doter d'outils pour
évaluer l'efficacité des aides publiques
mais le maintien d'une logique d'aide
par geste est-elle compatible
économiquement et administrativement
avec la systématisation d'une évaluation
avant et après les travaux de rénovation
est-ce tout simplement possible alors
que la fiabilité des DPE reste
questionnée
enfin la cour demandé de renforcer
l'accompagnement des ménages la
Commission souhaite donc que vous
puissiez faire un point d'étape du
déploiement du réseau France rénov dont
vous êtes maître d'ouvrage délégué avant
de vous laisser la parole pour répondre
à ses premières questions et pour un
propos introductif d'une vingtaine de
minutes il me revient de vous indiquer
que cette audition est diffusée en
direct et en différé sur le site du
Sénat et qu'un compte rendu sera publié
il m'appartient également de vous dire
que bien évidemment un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête serait
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-1 14 et
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 à 100.000 euros d'amende je
vous invite donc à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la liberté
à lever la main droite et à dire je le
jure
je le jure je vous remercie vous avez
donc la parole pour une vingtaine de
minutes et ensuite notre rapporteur vous
posera un certain nombre de questions
complémentaires et nous ouvrirons aussi
le débat avec l'ensemble de nos
collègues qui sont ici présent je vous
laisse la parole monsieur le
coordinateur
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs tout d'abord
merci pour cette invitation et pour
m'entendre sur le fait de la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments je
souhaiterais commencer mon intervention
par des rappels généraux sur la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments je
pense ça peut être utile pour la
structuration et l'explication du rôle
de la mission c'est ce que j'évoquerai
dans un deuxième temps et enfin je me
permettrai quelques éléments d'état des
lieux qui seront introductifs
probablement des questions que vous
aurez à me poser avant toute chose je
souhaitais également rappeler mais vous
l'avez indiqué que j'étais nommé le 15
juin dernier donc je n'ai pas en
personne tout l'historique de la
politique publique et j'ai pas non plus
d'historique même de la coordination
interministérielle et de son origine
mais je vous éclairais évidemment au
meilleur de mes connaissances et des
recherches que j'ai pu faire
voilà bon ces points sont évidemment
sont des évidences il semblait utile de
les rappeler dans ce propos introductif
commençons par les rappels généraux
en premier lieu je souhaiterais revenir
vraiment sur le parc de bâtiments on
parle bien d'un parc résidentiel et d'un
parc terci de secteur tertiaire avec
dans chacun des deux cas une
décomposition publique privée donc pour
le résidentiel un parc social et un parc
de résidence privée et pour le tertiaire
la même dichotomie entre intercir
publique état collectivité notamment
mais aussi un tertiaire privé
on a des segments qui sont donc
spécifiques mais par contre les
objectifs qui sont communs et l'objectif
commun il est il est connu il est rédigé
dans la stratégie nationale bas carbone
c'est une réduction des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre qui s'accompagne
également d'une réduction d'énergie avec
un objectif selon les origines que l'on
prend 49 % de réduction gaz à effet de
serre en objectif pour 2030 par rapport
à 2015 et 23% de réduction pour ce qui
est de l'énergie finale sur le même le
même laps de temps
ce sont des efforts importants mais qui
se sont que des étapes par rapport aussi
à 2050 vers la neutralité carbone
il est clair que lorsque l'on prend ses
objectifs et que l'on ajoute à cela
évidemment le nombre de logements 30
millions de logements le nombre de
mètres carrés un million 1000 millions
de mètres carrés en secteur tertiaire on
a un constat qui est que chaque progrès
compte il faut agir vite voire même très
vite on se dit il y a une forme
d'empressement il faut accélérer
toutefois je pense qu'il est important
de garder en tête que la rénovation
c'est quand même un sujet extrêmement
complexe pour le logement on touche à
l'espace de vie des ménages pour ce qui
est évidemment des entreprises elles
peuvent avoir d'autres priorités les
priorités économiques en premier lieu et
par ailleurs le bâtiment reste un objet
complexe
on est sur donc structurellement avant
de parler de la politique publique
elle-même on est sur un acte rénové qui
lui-même
découle de décision complexes et qui est
en tant que tel un acte compliqué
et si je crois ce qui explique aussi le
besoin d'une action publique qui a
besoin de s'appuyer à la fois sur des
dispositifs incitatifs on va en parler
je pense assez longuement mais aussi de
s'appuyer sur des outils réglementaires
des obligations des interdictions et la
politique publique je reviens sur mes
segments à bien choisir
d'avoir des approches différentes selon
mon segment dont on parlions en secteur
tertiaire on a une approche qui est
davantage basée sur des obligations
réglementaires là où du côté du logement
privé on a aussi tout un ensemble
d'incitations il y a également aux
obligations mais il y a aussi un
ensemble incitation et donc ce paysage
est implanté
je souhaitais mentionner que la
coordination gouvernementale la
rénovation dont je m'occupe à vocation à
être ensemble liée et avoir le regard
dans son billet de cette politique
publique
il est clair également on y reviendra
que je ne peux pas pour autant être
derrière chacune des différentes des
différentes actions
l'essentiel de mon rôle est de m'assurer
que les objectifs et l'objectif que je
mentionnais à gaz à effet de serre
réduction d'énergie reste l'objectif
principal poursuivi dans chacun de ces
différents segments
par ailleurs et c'est un point conclusif
de cette de ce paysage quand on a
mentionné évidemment le nombre on se dit
que c'est urgent quand on a rappelé
aussi les échéances on est aussi sur une
politique de long terme et donc il faut
que les dispositifs que l'on mette en
place est des effets de long terme qui
soit dispositifs suffisamment puissant
pour cela
on en arrive à la coordination
gouvernementale
alors la personne qui m'a précédé vous
l'avez mentionné a été nommé par une
lettre de mission qui du premier octobre
2019 qui est donc cosigné par Emmanuel
wargon et par Julien de Normandy quand
j'étais pas présent à la création donc
je me méfie donc sur la lettre mission
même peut-être l'avez-vous voulu
il est clair qu'en terme de contexte
et je cite les résultats en matière de
rénovation énergétique sont jugés à
l'époque comme n'étant pas à la hauteur
c'est le terme qui est retenu il est
également fait mention du fait qu'il y a
une demande d'accélération de la
rénovation énergie énergétique cette
demande découle des citoyens eux-mêmes
et il est fait mention en particulier
des remontées lors du grand débat
national donc c'est ça le contexte
de création de la mission coordination
mais on était en 2019 dans un contexte
qui est quand même bien différent de
celui que l'on a aujourd'hui on y
reviendra dans quelques instants
sur le rôle tel qu'elle est mentionné
dans les lettres de l'époque la mission
est chargée de mobiliser les acteurs
publics dans un cadre mieux coordonné
les lettres identifient explicitement
Lana l'ADEME les filières du bâtiment et
de l'énergie et l'objectif mentionné il
est clair il est explicité il faut
permettre une accélération significative
du rythme des rénovations et c'est ça
l'objectif et le mandat qui est confié à
la mission coordination
et donc il est demandé de piloter de
suivre la politique publique
et de mettre en place une organisation
en mode projet autour de la rénovation
énergétique de manière à produire les
résultats de cours et moyens termes mais
il est bien précisé que ces activités
ont vocation à être exécutées sans se
substituer à l'action des
administrations centrales et à ce titre
il est clair que la mission de
coordination n'est pas une délégation
interministérielle ne vient pas en plus
des administrations centrales
travaillant autour de la rénovation mais
elle vient en complément et elle est là
pour assurer un collectif de travail au
sein de l'administration centrale
donc aujourd'hui
pardon la seconde lettre de mission qui
est venue compléter la première cette
seconde lettre de mission a été signée
le 26 avril 2021 j'entre pas dans le
détail elle décrit de manière plus
précise les objectifs des mois suivants
aujourd'hui la coordination
gouvernementale pour le plan de
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments et
c'est une direction de projet
d'administration centrale elle est
doublement rattachée à la Direction
générale de l'aménagement logement en
nature et la direction générale énergie
climat donc très concrètement je
rapporte à la directrice générale
aménagement logement nature et je j'ai
également un rattachement opérationnel
auprès du directeur général d'énergie et
du climat
se rattachement formel s'est fait à
l'occasion de la réorganisation de la
dgln qui a eu lieu juste avant mon
arrivée donc dans l'organigramme on
trouve bien la coordination
gouvernementale ça a été ça a été
clarifié effectivement donc au début de
l'année 2022
comme je l'évoquais on est dans un dans
une démarche de collectif de travail on
n'est pas dans une logique d'ajouter une
couche
d'administration qui vient faire
travailler
les administrations contributrices on
est dans une logique
d'animation on est dans une logique de
faire partie du collectif dgndgec qui au
sein de migration centrale vient
finalement réaliser et vient élaborer la
politique publique en matière de
rénovation énergétique et donc on est au
carrefour de ce monde énergie et habitat
et effectivement l'un des points de la
coordination c'est de s'assurer que le
monde énergique effectivement est aligné
avec le monde habitat et on s'assure que
les décisions
prises de part et d'autre sont
effectivement pleinement cohérentes
et donc outre l'effectif de mon équipe
je pense qu'il faut aussi bien entendu
compter les dizaines de personnes au
sein de la dgln des HP et au sein de la
DGEC le service climat air service
climat et énergétique qui travaille à la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments en
complément de ça bien entendu il faut
ajouter aussi les dizaines de personnes
qui travaillent sur ces sujets au sein
de Lana et au sein de l'ADEME avec
lesquels également nous sommes en
relation donc mon équipe est intégrée je
crois que je crois que c'est Manuel
vargon qui a quelques semaines
mentionnés ici que elle souhaitait qu'il
y ait une équipe qui se lève le matin en
pensant rénovation énergétique donc je
confirme la coordination gouvernementale
se lève le matin en pensant rénovation
énergétique vu que c'est son mandat
unique et c'est à ce titre là qu'on a
cette casquette d'être ensemble la
politique publique on est également en
équipe transverse
ce que je souhaite dire par là c'est que
nous sommes organisés par typologie
d'usagers
là où les administrations centrales vont
plus classiquement être organisés par
typologie d'outils et par outils
réglementaire donc concrètement
aujourd'hui
outre ma personne la corniche
gouvernementale compte six postes
je vais les lister en un comme ça vous
aurez la vision l'explication très
concrète il y a un poste sur le parcours
usagé au sein de du service public
il y a un poste sur la rénovation du
parc locatif privé et les copropriétés
un poste sur l'offre de travaux et la
lutte contre la fraude il y a ensuite
trois postes sur les bâtiments
tertiaires dont deux postes sont en fait
des créations récentes puisqu'elles
découle de la création du fond vert qui
a lieu il y a quelques il y a quelques
semaines
je pourrais revenir dans les questions
sur le mode d'action de manière très
opérationnelle comment on travaille avec
la dgln et la DGEC mais effectivement
l'effectif de cette équipe est à mettre
au regard du collectif de travail dans
lequel on s'inscrit et les différentes
sous-directions que nous animons au
quotidien
et donc nous n'avons évidemment pas la
capacité et ce n'était pas l'intention
de d'être dans une situation de piloter
intégralement la politique publique on
est bien dans une démarche où nous
contribuons au collectif et nous animons
ce collectif au regard des objectifs qui
sont fixés à la politique publique
j'en arrive à mon troisième point qui
est peut-être un état des lieux et
quelques surtout
une présentation rapide des grands
dossiers qui qui m'anime
depuis 2020 il y a eu de très fortes
évolutions à la politique publique donc
depuis la création de la mission la
politique publique en elle-même a
énormément évolué je pense que les
auditions des ministres ont été plus
éclairantes que ce que je vais moi même
dire
mais je me permets de rappeler donc
premièrement la création de la prime de
transition énergétique ma prime rénove
qui
accompagnait des certificats d'économie
d'énergie qu'il ne faut évidemment pas
oublier ont permis réellement la
massification des gestes de rénovation
ce qui me permet de revenir sur le
mandat qui était fixé
en fin 2019 où on était très clairement
sur une demande qui était d'accélérer
significativement le rythme
c'est cette accélération et c'est sur
cette accélération qui a été évaluée
l'avancée de la politique publique et il
est clair que dans la démarche la
politique publique en matière de
rénovation énergétique a été érigée sous
le sein des réformes prioritaires du
gouvernement et maintenant un des
chantiers des politiques prioritaires du
gouvernement dans les indicateurs suivis
en relation avec la dictée
la rénovation énergétique en fait partie
et les indicateurs de suivi sont
précisément sur le nombre de gestes de
rénovation donc c'est sur cette base là
que nous avons été collectivement au
service de l'État évalué
le deuxième point d'évolution très fort
depuis 2020 c'est évidemment la loi
climat résilience que vous connaissez là
aussi mieux que moi qui vient définir un
cadre réglementaire en particulier qui
vient créer des obligations qui
n'existaient pas auparavant
obligation et interdiction bien entendu
j'ajoute en termes de points centraux le
lancement de la marque unique France
Renov la bannière qui permet de
renforcer le service public qui permet
évidemment de garantir une information
un conseil une orientation des ménages
qui puisse être neutre et indépendant
évidemment politique publique qui se
fait en relation avec les collectivités
territoriales qui se fait même grâce aux
collectivités territoriales pour le dire
directement
et enfin je dirais dans les points les
plus récents et les évolutions les plus
récentes je tenais à souligner aussi
l'arrivée du Secrétariat à la
planification écologique
qui me paraît assez central puisqu'il
vient apporter un niveau complémentaire
de coordination mais avec un mandat
précis qui est celui de cette de ce
regard pluriannuel et de cette
planification de long terme et donc il
me paraît être un acteur alors nouveau
dont on n'a pas encore perçu toutes les
conséquences opérationnelles au point de
vue des services mais qui évidemment
change la donne en termes de travail
également et en termes de perspective
pour nous
donc ça c'était on va dire le tour
d'horizon de ce qui a changé donc
aujourd'hui quels sont les dossiers sur
lesquels nous travaillons alors il y en
a très nombreux je vais pas tous les
lister je me permets simplement de
donner ceux sur lesquels mon équipe est
la plus impliquée
alors je souhaitais mentionner la
mobilisation de la filière pour
respecter les obligations de la loi
climat résilience sur le parc locatif
privé pas plus tard qu'il y a quelques
minutes des invitations ont été lancées
pour une réunion dite feuille de route
sur le parc locatif privé donc dans une
quinzaine de jours
sous la présidence du ministre Olivier
Klein dont l'objectif est bien de
mobiliser la filière pour ensemble
définir les actions qui peuvent être
prises pour que ces interdictions de
mise en location qui ont commencé à se
déployer des cette année puissent
effectivement être respecté dans les
prochaines années et donc le travail de
fond de préparation de ces de ces
éléments d'identification des
indicateurs qui permettent de suivre
l'entrée en vigueur de cette mesure sont
les points qui sont définis au sein de
mon équipe
deuxième point que ce thème mentionné et
qui nous occupe l'entrée en vigueur de
mon accompagnateur et novembre
donc le dispositif est entré en vigueur
au 1er janvier 2023 avec un certain
nombre de dispositifs
vont se décliner au cours de l'année
2023 et de l'année 2024 et plus
généralement cette thématique s'inscrit
aussi dans le sujet plus général du
service public de la rénovation de
l'habitat dont on parlera un peu plus
tard
troisième point sur lequel nous sommes
particulièrement impliqués c'est la
lutte contre la fraude ou plus
généralement la lutte contre l'écho
délinquance puisque nous animons un
groupe de travail un terme ministériel
sur la lutte contre la fraude et enfin
je souhaitais mentionner également dans
les travaux qui nous occupent
particulièrement
le fond vert donc la définition pour
du chapitre relatif à la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments des
collectivités pour le
dans le cadre du fond vert nouvellement
créé
voilà pour le tour d'horizon que je
souhaitais mentionner j'en ai fini sur
ces profonds introductifs il y a
évidemment d'autres points que
certainement que sur lesquels vous
souhaitez que je revienne mais je suis à
votre écoute pour vos questions
merci beaucoup pour ces premiers propos
et donc je laisse la parole à notre
rapporteur
merci merci beaucoup et merci pour pour
vos explications et
le
détail de vos de vos missions peut-être
revenir sur
peut-être commencer par par la fin de ce
que de ce que vous avez dit peut-être
sur la question justement du déploiement
de France rénov
parce que c'est à la fois quelque chose
qui est qui est nouveau mais qui est
important et c'est vrai que les
différents ministres qu'on a pu
auditionner je pense ont tous dit en
fait sur la politique en matière de
rénovation thermique il y avait à la
fois la question de la simplicité de
l'accès de faire en sorte que ça soit
simple évidemment du coup
l'accompagnement qui peut y avoir autour
et puis de la visibilité de la
durabilité dans les politiques dans les
politiques publiques
et donc ça je pense que c'est partagé
par tous et c'est un petit peu justement
comment comment on arrive à mettre à la
fois cette simplicité et puis cette
cette visibilité
sur la mise mise en place de France
rénov moi j'avais quand même pas mal de
questions sur c'est vrai que c'est prêt
c'est présenté justement comme une
simplification et notamment vers le
parcours des ménages
est-ce qu'on pourrait en savoir un petit
peu plus justement sur le à la fois le
déploiement et puis la mission réelle de
mon accompagnateur Renov et puis le lien
avec les collectivités c'est vrai que
j'ai récemment rencontré des
collectivités notamment intercommunalité
qui avait mis en place des
plateformes de rénovation avec des
résultats plutôt intéressants un
mécanisme justement assez simple et puis
avec une impression justement qu'on
vient encore modifier avec des canaux
notamment d'aide de subventions etc qui
sont qui sont très très complexes
le fameux speh la service public de la
performance énergétique de l'habitat qui
a également été remis au goût du jour
enfin en tout cas remis en place et qui
vient encore je dirais
manque de lisibilité donc je voulais
savoir comment justement vous arriviez à
dans ce dans ce cadre là arrivé à
travailler et à faire en sorte justement
qu'on aille vers quelque chose de
beaucoup plus de beaucoup plus simple
donc ça c'était de manière de manière
générale sur la mise en place justement
de la politique et autour de France
Renov et puis ensuite sur peut-être plus
plus précisément sur vos actions est-ce
que notamment sur la question du label
RGE sur lequel aussi on peut se poser
des questions et le lien avec à la fois
les professionnels les organismes de
formation et de certification est-ce que
du coup vous avez un rôle dans ce dans
ce cadre là et de la même manière sur le
DPE est-ce que du coup vous jouez ce
rôle là sur le suivi puisqu'il y a la
mise en place du nouveau DPE mais de la
même manière ce que nous ont dit à peu
près tous les tous les ministres que
nous avons auditionnés c'est qu'on a
besoin d'avoir un système en tout cas un
DPE qui fonctionne et sur lequel on
puisse s'appuyer si on veut mettre
ensuite en place des politiques
publiques claires et efficace et donc
comment justement ce suivi se fait
autour des des différents enfin de
l'évolution en tout cas des DPE voilà je
m'arrêtais là parce que je pense que
s'il y a d'autres d'autres questions
puis rebondiraient sur ce que vous
pouvez vous pouvez nous dire merci
vous avez un petit bouton devant le
micro devant voilà pardon excusez-moi
donc en préambule de de vos questions je
vais me permettre de développer la
manière dont nous travaillons
je l'évoquais donc on est à cheval entre
la dgln et la DGC ou à mi-chemin entre
la dégel et la DFC si je peux utiliser
ce terme on agit généralement de trois
manières soit on est en pilotage de
projet dans ce cas là on est
principalement dans un rôle de porter un
projet qui n'est pas porte qui
précisément pas spécifiquement porté par
un par un autre ou par une autre
organisation donc ça va être l'exemple
du reporting on a du reporting à faire
sur les politiques prioritaires du
gouvernement ou les objets de la vie
quotidienne on peut avoir l'élaboration
de la mesure rénovation énergétique sur
le fond vert qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure
où ça peut être effectivement le
déploiement ces République France rénov
donc ça c'est un d'action on a un
deuxième mode d'action qui est plutôt
l'animation d'équipe
donc j'évoquais tout à l'heure
la feuille de route pour mobiliser les
propriétaires d'ailleurs pour garantir
que le parc locatif privé puisse
finalement s'adapter aux nouvelles
mesures réglementaires là on est
clairement dans un rôle plutôt
d'animation
idem pour ce qui est du groupe de
travail sur la fraude qui réunit un
certain administration on est vraiment
en rôle en impulsion d'animation et le
dernier mode d'action de la coordination
de ma modeste équipe on est on appuie et
dans ce cas là on est
on est la voix de l'usager
au sein des travaux des administrations
et on vient rappeler à nos autres
directeurs sous directeur
d'administration centrale ce que
penserait l'usager dans tel et telle
situation face à telle ou tel objet de
la politique publique donc je me permets
de rappeler ces trois points puisque
donc
par rapport aux différents
à vos différentes questions premièrement
sur France rénov
là aussi je pense que il est important
de revenir sur là où nous en étions il y
a encore quelques quelques temps
sans refaire un historique sur les 20
dernières années puisqu'il y a eu
effectivement un certain nombre
d'évolution en 2021 la décision est
prise de lancer la marque France Renov
et de confier le réseau à Lana
en 2022 lancement opérationnel du réseau
et du service public multicanal avec
donc le site internet le numéro de
téléphone et bien entendu s'appuyant sur
les guichets et
forçait de constater que sous cette
bannière on est passé d'un petit millier
de conseillers dans les territoires à
selon le dernier des comptes que j'ai un
peu plus de 2250 conseillers répartis
sur 550 espaces conseils France rénov
donc on peut effectivement considérer
que ce n'est pas encore assez néanmoins
il y a eu quand même un net progrès sur
cette sur cette dimension là et j'ajoute
mais ça déjà été dit qu'évidemment c'est
de ce déploiement se fait grâce aux
collectivités territoriales donc mon
point n'est pas de dire que
c'est quelque chose qui n'était pas fait
auparavant il y a effectivement des on
va dire des des
initiatives et des démarches qui
préexistaient et qui fonctionnaient mais
l'esprit de ce qui est mis en place
aujourd'hui bien de créer un dispositif
sous une bannière nationale qui a
vocation a créé cette marque de
confiance dont les Français ont besoin
pour qu'ils puissent s'engager dans les
travaux de rénovation énergétique et
donc le l'élément central c'est comment
créer cette ce climat de confiance et
comment créer un service public qui va
permettre effectivement de donner au
ménages
un point d'accès simple dans le parcours
de rénovation
cela nous amène à l'accompagnement là
aussi l'accompagnement n'est pas un
objet créé en 2022 ou en 2023
l'accompagnement c'est un dispositif qui
existait auparavant en particulier dans
les dispositifs d'aide à la pierre de
Lana et l'objectif principal de mon
accompagnateur Renov n'est pas de
repeindre les dispositifs préexistants
sous la bannière mon accompagnateur
rénov l'objectif est de déployer et de
massifier les rénovations globales
et donc l'objectif est bien d'étendre ce
qui était fait
et d'augmenter la capacité donc le les
collectivités territoriales
font partie des acteurs qui peuvent
devenir mon accompagnateur rénov de fait
elles le sont déjà elles ont un agrément
elles vont avoir un agrément à demander
pour pouvoir poursuivre cette mission de
mon accompagnateur et neuve et la
logique qui a été introduite dans la loi
climat et résilience c'est que les
accompagnateurs rénov étaient en fait
ouvert également aux acteurs privés sous
réserve qu'ils passent le même agrément
en tout cas un agrément adapté à leur
situation pour pouvoir augmenter cette
capacité d'action et donc l'objectif
n'est pas en tout cas tel que la
politique publique a été rédigé n'est
pas de
balayer d'un revers de main ou
d'empêcher les collectivités
territoriales de faire l'accompagnement
l'objectif est d'augmenter la capacité
d'accompagnement dans son ensemble pour
que les ménages puissent trouver un
accompagnateur et qu'il n'y ait pas de
problème capacitaire en termes de nombre
d'accompagnateurs disponibles et donc
c'est ça c'est ça l'objectif principal
ensuite qu'il y ait le choix a été fait
de de
un dispositif où on s'appuie à la fois
sur les acteurs historiques plutôt du
côté associatif et du côté des
collectivités donc côté public et de
s'appuyer en même temps sur secteur
privé évidemment ce dispositif crée des
cette situation publique privée créer
des difficultés opérationnelles de mise
en œuvre avec la création d'un agrément
avec du coup des textes réglementaires
qui sont quand même d'un certain niveau
de complexité c'est pour ça que ça prend
un petit peu de temps à se mettre en
place pour autant le l'objectif qui est
la montée en puissance me semble
me semble salutaire puisque c'est
précisément l'une des réponses que l'on
doit apporter à la situation actuelle
qui est que aujourd'hui la politique lui
fait principalement du geste
un point relatif toujours sur le service
public la rénovation de l'habitat il est
clair que le l'objectif de simplicité
que l'on cherche pour le ménage est
susceptible de se traduire par une
complexité opérationnelle en particulier
dans les phases transitoires pour les
collectivités territoriales et pour les
acteurs de service public lui-même en
voulant écranter pour le ménage et
finalement les complexités
opérationnelles d'administration on
obtient des phases transitoires qui sont
difficiles
on en a conscience mais qui sont aussi
inévitables si on souhaite pouvoir créer
un parcours de l'usager qui soit aussi
limpide que possible là où je vais en
venir en disant cela c'est que on a
l'objectif de créer un service public de
la rénovation de l'habitat qui ne soit
pas uniquement centré sur la rénovation
énergétique pure mais qui puisse
répondre aux enjeux de l'habitat au sens
large
là aussi c'est pas une invention c'est
quelque chose que les activité
territoriale elle-même ont pu
expérimenter à divers endroits il y a
des maisons uniques de l'habitat qui
existent des guichets uniques de
l'habitat qui existent maisons de
l'habitat l'idée c'est bien de pouvoir
se donner les moyens de développer
autant que possible ces schémas à
l'échelle nationale mais tout en
acceptant les spécifistes et
territoriales et donc ça ne peut se
faire qu'avec la collaboration bien
entendu et la participation active des
collectivités territoriales et donc le
passage d'un dispositif où on avait
il y a encore quelques années des
espaces faire animer par l'ADEME vers un
dispositif futur dans lequel on est sur
un service public de la rénovation de
l'habitat créer une habitablement sur
plusieurs années
des transformations au niveau du service
public au sein des collectivités
territoriales au sein des acteurs auprès
des gens qui portent au quotidien ces
politiques publiques c'est compliqué on
en a effectivement conscience mais on se
dit tout c'est que évidemment l'objectif
est de le faire pour qu'il y ait une
chimie un de l'usagers qui soient plus
simple et que le ménage puisse y
retrouver derrière la bannière France
rénov donc c'est ça l'objectif
je continue sur le label
alors sur le comme on le disait mon
accompagnateur et en vigueur
progressivement au cours de 2023
nous avons le financement du service
public de la rénovation le SPEA service
public de performance énergétique de
l'habitat assuré par le programme SAR
qui dont les conventions s'arrêtent au
31 décembre 2023 donc nous avons en 2023
inévitablement
des discussions à avoir sur la suite la
suite elle est garantie il est évident
qu'au 1er janvier 2024 le service public
continue la question c'est quel est le
schéma cible à quel moment peut-on
mettre en place donc ce que je peux dire
aujourd'hui c'est que oui au 1er janvier
2024 le financement est garanti les
modalités précises sont encore en cours
de définition mais le financement est
garanti et ensuite le schéma cible la
date d'entrée en vigueur de chez massif
dépendra évidemment du dialogue que nous
aurons avec les collectivités
territoriales on a mis un certain nombre
de dans la réglementation on a mis un
jalon au 1er juillet 2024 sur
[Musique]
l'accostage entre mon accompagnateur et
neuve et les opérations programmées de
l'habitat par exemple c'est un exemple
de jalon mais je pense que c'est jalons
pourront être discuté avec les
collectivités territoriales
sur le pardon
du coup vous ne confirmez bien que il y
a quand même on est dans une phase de
problématique quand même de liens avec
les collectivités sur la mise en place
en fait de cette de cette procédure quoi
enfin de
je pense que ce que l'on peut dire c'est
que les collectivités territoriales sont
en attente
de connaître les modalités de
financement du service public au 1er
janvier 2024 c'est normal la demande est
totalement légitime on y travaille
d'arrache-pied
donc évidemment je pense que ça crée
auprès des collectivités territoriales
des questions et des interrogations sur
voilà comment comment se situe comment
se comment fonctionnera la suite je
pense que le point central que je
souhaitais mentionner c'est au premier
janvier 24 oui il y aura des
financements et il y aura un système qui
sera en place et on fera en sorte qu'il
soit le le moins disruptif possible pour
pouvoir poursuivre le service public
mais en parallèle on souhaite
effectivement pouvoir discuter du schéma
cible
dans l'objectif que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure d'un service public de la
rénovation de l'habitat
je reprends vos questions sur le label
RGE alors
c'était pour cette raison que j'évoquais
en particulier le les différents modes
d'action de la coordination
pour le label Hergé on est typiquement
dans une situation dans lequel mon
équipe on nous intervenons un rôle
d'appui donc on est la voie de l'usager
dans les réflexions autour de la belle
RGE donc la belle RGE et pilotée
principalement par la DHP
donc ce que je peux ce que je peux
mentionner malgré tout parce que on en
suit l'actualité bien entendu vous
doutez aujourd'hui on est principalement
sur une démarche de veille du suivi des
évolutions qui ont été apportées aux
dispositif RGE donc nous on intervient
sur les certaines réflexions internes
sur les évolutions dispositifs notamment
en matière de formation
en matière de montée en puissance sur le
nombre d'entreprises RGE on évoquait
tout à l'heure le fait qu'il était
plutôt en stagnation
et par ailleurs le fait que on avait
également un besoin d'améliorer la
capacité de la filière à recruter et on
avait une difficulté de d'attractivité
d'ensemble ça c'est les points sur
lesquels nous intervenons
je peux mentionner en particulier le
fait qu'on a contribué à par exemple des
campagnes de communication en 2022 pour
le l'attractivité de la filière mais
effectivement le cœur des activités
autour de la belle sont du côté de la
DHP et on est plutôt des contributeurs
indirects sur cette sur ce point du côté
du DPE on intervient de la même manière
du coup sur le sur le RGE justement
selon vous et sur le regard que vous
avez pu avoir
à la fois sur sa mise en place et puis
son évolution
[Musique]
vous en avez plutôt enfin de se dire que
ce label là est la mise en place de ce
Labella a été plutôt positif et c'est
plutôt une liste positive et le fait de
pouvoir le poursuivre ou est-ce qu'il y
a quand même une réflexion sur sur son
évolution ou sur d'autres je dis ça
parce que je pense à certains
pays par exemple qui fonctionnent
différemment qui ont pas forcément de
labellisation sur les entreprises mais
plutôt un contrôle en fin de chantier en
fait sur la qualité et le résultat en
fait des travaux et c'est vrai que je
sais qu'il y avait aussi une réflexion
d'ailleurs l'un et l'autre d'ailleurs
puisque c'est pas forcément mais savoir
si du coup il y avait ce type de
réflexion qui était alors on a bien
connaissance des dispositifs alternatifs
qui peuvent exister d'ailleurs ces
dispositifs existent parfois aussi en
France sur d'autres sujets que la
rénovation énergétique le fait d'aller
contrôler par exemple domaine de
l'électricité par exemple ou du gaz
à ce stade il n'y a pas de travaux
internes qui à remettre en cause les
fondamentaux du label RGE les réflexions
internes et les travaux qui existent au
sein de nos services sont plutôt sur une
réflexion autour de faire évoluer
le dispositif de l'améliorer mais il n'y
a pas de travaux qui vise à le refondre
intégralement et
effectivement renverser la table de la
démarche
les entreprises se plaignent de la
complexité des démarches et voilà
souhaiteraient une simplification qui
les amènerait plus facilement à
s'inscrire dans cette démarche de RGE
oui on en a enfin on en a c'est
effectivement les signaux qui nous
envoient après il les les fédérations je
pense
sont aussi moteurs de ce de cette de ce
label je pense que en tout cas pour ce
que j'envoie la DGP est aussi à l'écoute
de des remontées des différentes des
différentes filières il y a des
propositions qui ont été évoquées sur
notamment la formation
je pense que sont des points qui peut
être qui peut être instruits peuvent
être inscrits à l'ordre du jour
on a on entend également les les appels
du pied concernant la simplification ou
concernant les contrôles par exemple
on peut entrer dans le détail pour pour
ce que je peux connaître je connais pas
forcément tous les dispositifs
ma compréhension c'est que les points de
simplification qui étaient appelés qui
ont été rappelés un certain nombre de
contextes à ce stade il n'y a pas été il
n'a pas de suite a été donné parce que
les propositions qui étaient faites
n'étaient pas on pouvait pas les on
pouvait pas lui donner suite notamment
sur la simplification des contrôles tu
es fait appel le fait que il souhaitait
que les contrôles soient fusionnés de
manière complète entre les contrôles RGE
et les contrôles des aides que l'on peut
trouver du côté certificat d'économie
d'énergie ou du côté de ma prime rénov
chaque type de contrôle des gens
différents sur des objets différents et
donc parler de fusion des contrôles
n'est tout simplement faites pas
possible puisqu'on ne contrôle pas les
mêmes personnes les mêmes individus donc
pour prendre cet exemple que sur
lesquels je souhaitais souhaitais
rebondir mais je vous encourage à
solliciter la DHP de manière précise sur
ces sur ces questions et je pense qu'ils
seront à même de pouvoir vous répondre
j'enchaîne sur le DPE donc le la même
manière
le dépe est ensuite sur lequel nous
intervenons du côté de la mission
coordination en appui là aussi de la DHP
puisque c'est la DHP qui est en charge
définir les textes réglementaires
associés de manière générale j'ai
omis de le préciser la mission de
coordination dans son dans ses fonctions
donc animation pilotage de projets et
puis appuie nous n'avons pas de rôle
réglementaire nous n'avons pas de rôle
budgétaire donc on s'appuie sur les
services
DGL DGEC pour ce qui est des textes
réglementaires et des budgets
donc sur le DPE on est en appui et un
choix a été fait en 2021 je crois qu'il
est assumé pleinement qui est de faire
en sorte que le DPE s'appuie sur les
caractères caractéristiques physiques du
logement
et donc la méthode a été mise en place
pour avoir
une description qui soit aussi fiable
qu'il est possible donc ce sont les
données renseignées par diagnostiqueurs
ce sont ça un ces données d'entrée et
ces données renseigner doivent être
pleinement justifiés
on peut regarder là où est le DP
aujourd'hui on peut aussi regarder là où
il était il y a deux ans on avait encore
des DPF vierges et DPE basé sur facture
donc il y a une amélioration très nette
qui a été qui a été permises et
l'essentiel des travaux aujourd'hui
porte sur la fiabilisation de la
réalisation du DPE c'est à dire qu'on ne
remet pas en cause la méthode et le
principe qui est de d'avoir un DPE qui
est basé sur les caractéristiques
physiques et on met tous nos efforts
l'essentiel des efforts sur les travaux
avec les filières diagnostiqueurs pour
que l'acte du diagnostic soit aussi
répétable qu'il est possible en
particulier comme je l'évoquais à
l'instant en allant au bout de la
démarche de justification des données
qui sont renseignées dans les DPE
là aussi je vous invite à solliciter la
DHP pour un dialogue plus précis sur les
travaux en cours mais il n'y a pas à ma
connaissance de travaux en cours qui
remettent en cause la méthodologie et le
principe que j'évoquais ici à savoir on
est basé sur des caractéristiques
physiques du logement
est-ce que nos collègues soient très
poser des questions
non Franck non plus
moi je serai opposé une question sur les
meublés de tourisme est-ce que
aujourd'hui compte tenu du fait que les
meublés de tourisme ne sont pas soumis à
l'interdiction de louer lorsqu'ils sont
considérés comme étant des passeports
thermiques et on entend que le
gouvernement voilà s'intéresse de près à
ce sujet là est-ce que vous vous avez
déjà été mobilisé sur le sujet est-ce
que vous allez l'être de quelle façon en
appui en animation
alors nous sur le sujet précis de
peut-on interdire ou peut-on étendre
l'interdiction aux meublés touristiques
il y a donc effectivement il y a une
volonté du cabinet du ministre de la
Ville et du Logement d'aller dans le
sens d'une interdiction de louer les
meubles et touristiques qui seraient des
passoires aujourd'hui moi je ne suis pas
en première ligne je sais qu'il y a des
travaux internes qui ont été qui ont été
sollicités donc le sujet est à l'étude
voilà je n'en connais pas les paramètres
je connais pas les limites juridique on
est sur un chèque vous n'avez pas été
moi personnellement
et potentiellement ça pourrait être
possible alors je pense que contenu de
la complexité du sujet de complexité
juridique probablement le sujet sera
envoyé la DHP qui possède effectivement
les juristes et les experts qui
permettront d'analyser de manière
détaillée cette cette question pour ce
qui me concerne je serai plutôt mobilisé
sur un sujet connexe qui est comment
fait-on pour éviter c'est pour que cette
éviction n'est pas lieu c'est-à-dire que
comment fait-on pour que le parc locatif
privé reste plein et entier et donc
c'est là où dans mon équipe nous
travaillons à ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure donc la feuille de route de
mobilisation des professionnels pour le
parc locatif privé et l'objectif est
d'identifier déjà les indicateurs que
l'on peut
identifier pour suivre l'entrée en
vigueur
des interdictions de mise en location
donc quels sont les signaux que l'on
peut réussir à capter comment les
interpréter
surinterpréter puisqu'il faut aussi
parfois être capable de déterminer
comment une dynamique s'inscrit dans une
dans un mouvement général
et donc nous on va être mobilisé plutôt
avec les professionnels
la FNAIM par exemple ou avec les
associations de de locataires pour
essayer de déterminer comment est-ce que
collectivement on prend des actions qui
vont permettre d'éviter effectivement
qu'il y ait par exemple une réduction du
parc locatif privé
sur la lutte contre la fraude est-ce que
vous pouvez un petit peu plus développer
quel est votre rôle exactement donc
à l'occasion des des offres à 1 euro il
y a quelques années
un certain nombre de situations fraudes
et ce que je qualifierais de non qualité
ont pu être remontés à l'époque au
ministère et donc la mission
coordination s'est vu confié un rôle qui
est un groupe de travail de lutte contre
la fraude de la rénovation énergétique
où là on est clairement dans un rôle
d'animation c'est-à-dire que nous
n'avons pas de rôle de sanction nous
n'avons pas de rôle de d'élaboration
d'une politique de contrôle mais on est
clairement dans un rôle de mise en
relation des acteurs qui au sein des
services de l'État on se rôle de
contrôle ont éventuellement un rôle de
sanction donc dans ce GT qui se réunit
de manière hebdomadaire nous avons la
DGCCRF
la DGL donc notamment les acteurs côté
tutelle Anna le pôle national des C2E au
sein de la Direction Générale énergie
climat le pnc2e donc Lana elle-même nous
avons la dame nous avons le service
central de renseignement criminel de la
direction générale à la gendarmerie
nationale et nous avons le service
d'information de renseignement et
d'analyse stratégique sur la criminalité
organisée de la direction générale la
police nationale donc nous nous
réunissons manière hebdomadaire
nous sommes principalement focalisés sur
des chantiers structurels c'est-à-dire
que dans ces réunions nous pouvons avoir
ponctuellement des partages très
opérationnels d'information quand les
textes réglementaires nous le permettent
donc partager des informations sur des
fraudes en cours typiquement on peut
partager également des schémas fraude
mais l'essentiel nos travaux sont autour
par exemple de l'élaboration des
messages de prévention à destination du
grand public peuvent être retour de
l'élaboration des conventions de partage
d'information entre chez nous faire en
sorte que si un schéma de fraude a été
identifié ici des interlocuteurs
frauduleux ou des entreprises
frauduleuses ont été
identifiés à tel endroit que c'est les
coordonnées peuvent être transmises à un
autre service par exemple
et on peut être amené à intervenir
également sur différents outils de
reporting pour permettre effectivement
le tout simplement au ménage et aux
citoyens de faire le reporting des
situations de fraudes donc on est sur
des chantiers plutôt structurels et à ce
stade on nous a pas confié d'autres
rôles que que celui-ci évidemment on est
plutôt bien positionné malgré tout pour
faire des propositions et pour
identifier et pour proposer
éventuellement des évolutions dans une
positif ce que nous faisons à
destination des cabinets ministériels
en tant que ce groupe de travail a été
mis en place alors il a été mis en place
en 2019
il s'est réuni plutôt avec une bonne
fréquence
et donc à ma connaissance en tout cas
depuis que je suis arrivé les réunions
hebdomadaires on se sont tenues de
manière quasi systématique voilà j'ai
pas l'historique complet comme je
l'évoquais mais depuis juin il y a une
réunion par semaine quasiment tout le
temps
le rapport de la Cour des comptes a
dénoncé l'absence d'une doctrine claire
entre la protection du patrimoine de la
transition écologique alors mon souci
c'est le patrimoine non protégé c'est à
dire pas je parle pas des monuments
historiques je ne parle pas des du
patrimoine qui est protégé dans les
documents d'urbanisme je parle bien de
des maisons de nos villages etc et je
j'aurais aimé savoir s'il existait un
travail conjoint entre les
administrations des ministères de la
transition écologique ministère de la
Culture et de l'agriculture sur ces
sujets pour qu'on puisse mieux tenir
compte des propriétés qui sont
spécifiques à ce type de bâti parce que
on se rend compte que avec les
techniques qui sont actuellement
conseiller les préconisations qui sont
faites par le DPE tel qu'il est
actuellement
pratiqué en fait vont à l'encontre des
spécificités de ce type de bâti
en premier lieu effectivement le
lorsqu'un ménage réalise un diagnostic
performance énergétique et des
préconisations un peu standards qui
peuvent être proposées elles sont dans
la main du diagnostiqueur mais la
réalité des préconisations de travaux
sont plutôt à aller chercher au sein
d'un autre outil réglementaire qui
s'appelle l'audits qui lui a vocation à
proposer des plans de travaux plus
précis et qui ont vocation effectivement
à donner des indications aux
propriétaires
qui sont on va dire plus plus complètes
pour répondre à votre question oui il
existe un groupe de travail entre le
ministère de la Culture et le musée des
ministères la transition écologique donc
là aussi c'est un groupe qui a entre une
des sous-directions de la DHP et
une entité de ministère et culture
excuse-moi j'ai oublié le nom de le nom
de l'entités donc ils vissent
précisément en fait à travailler donc
non pas sur le DPE comme je l'évoquais
juste avant mais pour travailler précis
précisément sur les typologies de
préconisations on retrouve par ailleurs
donc ce groupe de travail existe par
ailleurs il y a au sein des opérateurs
de l'État un certain nombre de bonnes
pratiques qui ont déjà été formulées qui
sont des outils que l'on peut mettre en
avant et qu'effectivement il est bon que
les architectes des bâtiments de France
mais aussi les services des concentrés
de l'État mais aussi pourquoi pas les
professionnels peuvent connaître donc
notamment au sein du serema il y a le
kreba qui a été qui a été mis en place
alors
l'acronyme je sais pas je vais
m'aventurer dans l'acronyme du crébat
mais il est question de bâtir ancien le
BEA c'est bâti ancien donc c'est un
centre de ressources très concrètement
donc il y a des bonnes pratiques qui
existent et effectivement dans ces
bonnes pratiques il n'y a pas de
spécificités faites sur le le classement
et le niveau de protection du patrimoine
on est bien effectivement sur pour ce
qui est du crébat de effectivement la
maison la maison de ferme le logis non
classé en zone rurale on est sur des
bâtis finalement assez assez classique
comme on peut en trouver dans nos dans
nos régions dans ces recommandations il
est clair que
je ne crois pas que le on trouve en tête
de gondole l'isolation thermique par
l'extérieur comme étant le l'élément
numéro 1 à réaliser lorsqu'on passe à
travers la roue du kreba donc je pense
qu'effectivement il y a des
préconisations qui existent des bonnes
pratiques ont été documentées et
effectivement il y a un travail à faire
qui est de diffuser ces bonnes pratiques
pour ne pas effectivement que des
préconisations qui iraient à l'encontre
du bon sens soit faite dans nos dans nos
villages
et ça vaut oui oui et ça vaut bien
entendu en zone urbaine tout à fait
juste une précision pour rebondir sur la
sur la question des des fraudes qui est
plutôt sur le quand on parlait justement
de simplicité où on a pas mal de retour
sur la totale sur ma prime rénove sur de
problématiques justement de
de personnes qui soient ont mal rempli
un dossier etc et de difficultés en fait
du droit à l'erreur tout simplement
je veux savoir si ça c'était quelque
chose sur lequel à la fois vous aviez
des remontées et si c'était important
c'est vrai qu'on nous a dit que
globalement par rapport au nombre de
dossiers c'était pas si important que ça
mais voilà enfin en tout cas c'est quand
même quelque chose qui existe en tout
cas la grande difficulté quand il y a
une problématique comme ça souvent qui
est très simple c'est de revenir en
arrière quoi et de et de pouvoir
régulariser cette cette situation donc
voir si du coup sur cet aspect là vous
vous aviez à la fois des remontées des
interventions et puis le lien entre
aide et subventions qui peuvent être
apportées et
coût des travaux
et augmentation du coût des travaux quoi
c'est-à-dire en gros d'avoir une
visibilité sur l'aide financière et
l'aide publique qui peut être apportée
et là où en fait elle va elle est fait
d'aubaine qui peut y avoir derrière sur
cette sur cette aide publique
sur le premier point portant sur le
les dossiers mal renseigner le droit à
l'erreur les éventuellement les
personnes qui n'auraient pas réussi à
aller au bout de leurs démarches
effectivement et j'ai envie de manière
assez objective lorsque l'on regarde les
nombres de dossiers
qui ont été qui ont été engagés donc
dossiers engagés signifient que le
ménage est allé à la fin de la première
phase du processus qui est d'obtenir un
accord de principe sur l'aide qu'il va
obtenir dans ma prime rénov on est sur
des chiffres qui sont extrêmement élevés
on est sur 2022 on est on est à plus de
600 000 on a une vingtaine 650 000 donc
on a des chiffres qui sont très élevés
et qui sont à mettre en relation avec
les quelques centaines de dossiers de
personnes qui n'ont pas réussi à aller
au bout de leur processus ou qui sont on
va dire dans une impasse
moi je vous encourage à solliciter Lana
sur ce sujet pour vous expliquer de
manière très détaillée ce qu'ils font
nous avons un suivi donc tutelle vers
Lana de manière précise sur le
traitement de ces dossiers et donc il y
a il y a des suivis réguliers sur les
dossiers dit en difficulté
qui a été mis en place et donc sans
entrer dans le détail et je pense que
Valérie montrétellor ou bien les
services de DHP le Franck plus de
précision que moi le
suivi est allé jusqu'à un appel
volontaire de la Navarre le ménage pour
s'assurer pour aider le ménage à aller
au bout du traitement de son dossier
donc comme une démarche de fond qui a
été faite pour un certain nombre de cas
pour un certain nombre de dossiers
aucune suite n'a été possible le ménage
n'était pas joignable ou ne répondez pas
donc il y a pu avoir des situations dans
lesquelles le traitement n'est pas allé
à son terme mais cela reste malgré tout
une volumétrie très limitée le point que
ça appelle également le fil que cela
tire c'est
dans un objectif de massification
effectivement des choix ont été faits
d'avoir une plateforme nationale je
pense que ce point-là a déjà discuter
avec avec les précédents lors des
précédentes auditions
je souhaitais préciser que l'ANA
travaille également à une convention
avec France services pour s'assurer pour
des ménages qui pourraient être en
situation de l'électronisme d'avoir un
accompagnement à l'outil et que les
ménages puissent être accompagnés de
manière individuelle par des personnes
pour pouvoir également aller au terme
d'un certain nombre de ces de ces
dossiers lorsque cela est nécessaire
tout en sachant que c'est déjà en
pratique quelque chose qui peut être
fait aussi directement par certains des
guichets des services publics dont je
parlais tout à l'heure donc il y a un
centre d'action qui sont mises en oeuvre
oui il y a certainement encore des
actions à faire pour aller encore plus
loin mais je pense qu'il y a quand même
beaucoup d'efforts qui ont été qui ont
été déployés sur cette sur cette
thématique qui reste un point de sujet
de focus comme je l'évoquais vu qu'on le
suit en direct depuis les tutelles sur
le lien entre les aides et le coût des
travaux
j'ai pas fait un listing complet de tous
les dossiers et tout ce que l'on suit un
petit public mais juste à dire
administratif ça ce document à trois qui
a 4,90 lignes c'est
ce que nous suivons des GEC déjàn
conjointement évidemment avec mon équipe
dans ce que font les opérateurs de
l'État sur la rénovation énergétique et
derrière chaque ligne il y a évidemment
des heures et des heures de travail
puisque là donc c'est un suivi
d'indicateur parmi ce que le parmi ceux
qui est suivi
il y a le montant des aides par rapport
au coût des travaux qui peuvent être
rapportés
dans ma prime rénove
Lana récupère le coût des travaux
donc on a un moyen assez clair et
instrumenté de vérifier que le montant
de l'aide est approprié par rapport au
montant moyen des travaux et donc on est
on a on a les outils pour permettre
finalement de d'ajuster les dispositifs
d'ajuster les paramètres pour éviter
autant que faire ce peu les effets
d'aubaine pour autant ça les élimine pas
complètement il peut y en avoir sur un
certain nombre de dispositifs et
effectivement l'un des l'un des
challenges c'est de les identifier le
plus tôt possible pour effectivement
apporter des correctifs sur les
dispositifs quand on le peut pour éviter
les effets d'aubaine et réciproquement
dans les situations d'inflation d'être
capable de faire des propositions
notamment à destination des tutelles
budgétaires pour être capable de le cas
échéant d'être capable d'ajuster des
dispositifs donc c'était la par exemple
au 1er janvier 2023 sur ma prime 9
sérénité le rehaussement d'un certain
nombre de plafonds pour permettre
effectivement d'accompagner la
rénovation les rénovations globales qui
sont faites dans le cas de ma prime
réno-stérité
s'assurer que les montants puissent être
mieux corrélés à l'augmentation des
coûts des travaux mais aussi de donner
un signal à destination de ses
propriétaires sur le fait qu'il fallait
s'engager plutôt dans ses travaux que
dans des gestes unitaires
est-ce que vous travaillez sur la
question des copropriétés ou pas
pour être tout à fait transparent donc
il y a bien une personne dans mon équipe
qui a vocation à travailler sur cette
thématique
on n'a pas encore commencé à s'y mettre
donc essentiellement les travaux
personnels relativement récemment
l'objectif sur les copropriétés
est assez analogue à celui que
j’évoquais tout à l'heure sur les
propriétaires bailleurs et les
transformations du parc locatif privé
donc notre objectif est à terme de
mettre en place la même démarche de
mobilisation des professionnels
notamment des syndics des professionnels
des syndics pour s'assurer que l'on va
pouvoir accompagner les propriétaires
qui ont des biens dans les dans ces
copropriétés les accompagner en cette
démarche de rénovation énergétique
l'essentiel des activités aujourd'hui
côté copropriété comme effectivement mon
équipe ne s'y est pas encore mis sur
cette thématique est assuré pleinement
par la DHP par la nappe par les acteurs
qui dont sait le cœur de métier tout en
sachant que sur copropriété lorsque je
m'attellerai à cette thématique je
prendrai la thématique sous l'angle de
la rénovation énergétique qui est l'un
des angles uniquement par lequel
regardez les problématiques de
copropriété puisqu'on y trouve
évidemment un grand nombre d'autres
sujets
sur voilà
l'habitat un digne insalubrité
copropriété en difficulté donc les
sujets sont
restent seront par ailleurs de toute
façon les citrons par ailleurs une
coordination avancée pour positionner la
rénovation énergétique de la bonne
manière par rapport aux autres
thématiques des copropriétés
merci beaucoup s'il y a plus de
questions on va vous remercier de cette
audition et vous souhaitez une bonne fin
de journée merci beaucoup à vous merci
Madame merci Monsieur pour votre
présentation très intéressante donc je
vais reposer une question que j'ai que
j'ai que j'ai posé il y a précédemment
[Musique]
voilà
est-ce que à votre avis
le la notation des TPE est amenée à se
dégrader dans le temps
c'est à dire la performance énergétique
à DPE donné est-ce que vous pensez
qu'elle peut elle peut se dégrader dans
le temps
auquel cas bon voilà ça pose un certain
nombre de questions vous pensez que je
comprenne bien la question vous pensez
du fait de la dégradation du bâti ou du
fait d'un objectif de positive du fait
de voilà de la nature de voir de la
qualité des matériaux utilisés des
process des process peut-être
énergétiques également voilà il y a un
process il y a un processus auquel
personne en échappe y compris nous c'est
le vieillissement et ça se pose aussi
évidemment pour pour toute structure
la caractère physique ou physique ou
chimique donc voilà le sens de ma
question
alors
très bonne question
alors je vais faire une réponse en vous
disant que en fait au contraire on
souhaiterait que les DPE en moyenne sur
le parc de bâtisse améliore vu que
l'objectif c'est de les rénover
donc
ça c'est mon premier commentaire
par rapport au DPE qui pourrait être
amené à se dégrader
je pense que en fait la problématique
est même un petit peu différente
le DPE comme on l'évoquait tout à
l'heure c'est une note qui est
conventionnelle c'est à dire que c'est
une convention qui définit la note par
l'issue d'une méthode dont les données
d'entrée sont
ce que le diagnostiqueur a renseigné sur
la base de ce qu'il peut justifier dans
un logement
j'ai envie de dire que s'il
diagnostiqueur sait qu'il y a telle
épaisseur de laine de verre dans un mur
en 2023 il pourra dire la même chose en
2030 si la laine de verre n'a pas été
bougé et donc il n'y a pas de raison que
le DPE soit différent donc le DPE
apportera probablement une autre
constante la réalité c'est plutôt une
réalité physique
voilà et donc c'est pour ça que je fais
un distinguo le DPE est une est une
description conventionnelle du logement
et donc par définition si j'ose dire le
DPE n'est qu'un proxy de la réalité
physique de sa consommation donc
peut-être ma réponse ne va pas être tant
être sûr est-ce que les de vont se
dégrader la réponse a plutôt être est-ce
que la performance énergétique des
bâtiments dans le temps peut se dégrader
alors je ne suis pas un expert je pense
c'est une question à poser certainement
aux experts bâtiments par exemple de
l'ADEME bon néanmoins on est quand même
un certain nombre de travaux très
probablement oui
on prend l'exemple d'isolation des
combles s'ils sont soumis à une humidité
particulière le niveau de performance
réelle du coup physique de l'isolation
peut être amené à baisser la même
manière alors c'est moins le cas
aujourd'hui avec les matériaux actuels
mais il y a quelques années on pouvait
par exemple craindre un tassement de
certains isolants conduisant à de
l'enveloppe du bâtiment ne soit pas
forcément bien
hermétiquement fermé mais qui puisse
avoir effectivement des soit des fuites
d'air soit des zones qui n'étaient plus
forcément aussi bien isolés que lors de
la mise en oeuvre du produit ces
choses-là sont c'est moins le cas
aujourd'hui et je pense qu'il faudrait
interroger des experts pour essayer de
comprendre les effets réels de ces de
ces dispositifs mais il peut y avoir
effectivement un effet de vieillissement
du bâti qui explique que de manière
comme comme finalement comme tout objet
physique il y a effectivement une forme
de maintenance une forme de de de
retour à faire de manière régulière sur
le sur les bâties ça vaut pour les
systèmes le système de chauffage
généralement une durée de vie d'une
quinzaine d'années mais ça vaut
effectivement aussi sur les enveloppes
du du bâti
un bâtiment n'est pas éternel même s'ils
ont une très longue durée de vie
merci beaucoup monsieur et bonne fin de
journée à vous merci